- I love it.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Oh my gosh.
Wait, can I see the back?
(Lisette laughs)
(audience cheering)
That's beautiful.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much.
- How gorgeous are you?
- Thank you so much. (laughs)
- And I see her, like,
at the crack of dawn,
before hair and makeup
and she still looks as gorgeous as this.
- All right, you know what?
I can't hear you right now, ma'am.
(laughs)
You probably look the same.
So, wait, so what impressed you,
Congratulations, first of all.
So excited for you for this series.
- Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] So cool.
- Thank you.
- And what, were you, like, I mean,
I know you had to have been excited,
but what impressed you about
working with Catherine?
'Cause this is, like,
one of the greats, right?
So, you're-
- Absolutely
- [Kelly] Getting to show
up and work with her.
- I mean, how could I
even choose one thing?
Like it's impossible.
Truly.
I think like one of the best things
about working with Catherine was
that she allowed me the
space to play, like with her.
And I think like as a,
you know, young actor
I was really nervous to like
get started and to, you
know, she's such a star.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But she was always so kind
and you welcomed me with open
arms since the beginning.
- I remember that being on this big set
for the first time where you have
so much responsibility-
- [Lisette] And pressure.
- This is our star.
And she is every inch
of that inside and out.
I mean, she really is an amazing talent,
but she's just has a wonderful
center and work ethic.
And I saw a little bit of myself in her
and sometimes I forget my lines
because I was watching her act.
- Oh, know. (laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh, that means
you're doing a great job.
- Oh, that would be my line.
Ok.
But no, it was just,
- That means you're nailing it.
So Lisette you're kind of taking
over for Nick Cage, right?
In the National Treasure series.
So, I mean, this's a huge franchise.
So tell us about your character.
- Yeah, so my character Jess Valenzuela,
she is a really smart,
determined young lady
who's living in Baton Rouge
kind of at the standstill in her life
after her mother passes away
that's where we pick up in the story.
She, one day gets this,
you know, maybe suggestion,
I'll call it, that from
Harvey Kietel's character
who plays Agent Sadusky.
Our characters kind of interact
and he tells her that a necklace
that she's had her whole life maybe
has something to do with this
great Pan-American treasure.
And even more her father might
have something to do with it.
And for Jess, she's never
had a relationship with her father.
So she's kind of at this point
in her life wanting to search
for familial ties, something
that will ground her again
so she decides to go after it.
- Yeah.
- It's a great, it's a great adventure.
- I know.
That's what I love about, like,
I love about the movies is
it takes you on this ride
like you were saying.
And I'm so excited about the series
except for whenever it ends
and you have to wait for the next episode.
But like, but then,
but it's like, it's one
of those things that's so exciting
because you go on the adventure
and you get to figure out the clues, like
with all the characters.
It's such a clever way to make a series
'cause everybody wants to keep watching.
How did you find out you got the part?
Like I heard it was a big deal.
Right?
- It was a huge deal.
- Yeah.
- So I actually had like a
really tedious audition process.
It was about, gosh, I wanna
say about a month long.
And I had, I'd done, you know,
I was auditioning every
single day, many scenes.
And I was at that point where I was like
are they gonna tell me or not?
I was so stressed.
- Yeah.
- And my mom was like,
let's just go shopping.
Like let's just go shopping,
distract ourselves.
And so I'm like, yes, I love shopping.
Let's go shopping.
Let's just, you know, do it.
- [Kelly] De-stress.
- Yes, exactly.
And so we're in this changing room
to a store that I guess
just has zero reception
and like, I'm changing and everything.
All of a sudden my phone just starts going
ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding, ding, ding.
And I'm like, (gasps)
Oh my God.
I look at it, it's my manager
And she's telling me like,
call me back right now.
I'm like, oh my god Mama, this is it.
This is it.
I don't know what I'm gonna do.
I'm like trying to change
back into my clothes.
I'm like giving her the clothes.
She's like, do I stand in line?
What do I do?
I was like, I don't know,
but I gotta go take the call.
I like go outside into the
to the alley or the hallway area
where like all the benches are.
Oh my god, that's me. (laughs)
(audience clapping)
Yeah.
(Kelly screaming)
Yeah it's like where I
summon my dad to go sit.
And so eventually I took the call,
I found out I got the part
and I just like immediately remember
like I start jumping up and down crying.
My mom noticed from inside the store.
She didn't care, she ran out.
Without the clothes, of course.
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
And yeah, we just celebrated that day.
It was amazing.
It was what we least expected.
- Oh my God.
Well I just, I saw that video
and it just made me like
smile on the inside.
Like never lose that joy.
Like such a beautiful thing to feel
that kind of like energy off something
that you've worked for.
Like, and it's happening.
It's really cool.
- Aw, thanks so much.
- I'm so glad you shared it with everyone.
It's such a beautiful moment.